you've got two options option one go
literal
and then this is completely against
science as william lane craig himself
knows
because you'd have to say that the
universe was created in six 24-hour days
and that is six thousand years old
or you go allegorical and if you go
allegorical you've still got the problem
of contradictory metaphors
it's the hijab 10 discount code for 10
discount on a wide range of products
including premium ethiopian black seed
products
how are you guys doing today i'm going
to be refuting william lane craig
dr william lane craig is a premier
season debate and apologists in the
christian world a scholar somebody who's
gone through the academic group
published many books
many many books in fact is almost uh 70
years old i think if not
he has passed that age so he's almost
double my age as somebody who's debated
some prominent figures from the atheist
community from even within his own
christian community and someone who
contributes and has done so
to the public discourse for i don't know
the last 30 40 years
what i'm going to be refuting him on is
his stance
on this genesis narrative in particular
and what he thinks
of it first of all let's take a look at
what he says in response to a question
that somebody asks from the audience and
then come back and comment on this
the first one the bible says god created
the earth
in seven days how does the big bang
theory fit
into this the big bang theory would be
incompatible with a literalistic
interpretation of genesis chapter 1. an
interpretation that
takes the days to be consecutive 24-hour
periods of time
however since the time of the church
fathers such as augustine
up until the present century most
biblical scholars
don't adopt that sort of literalistic
interpretation of the opening chapter
of genesis and i say that not on the
basis of modern science but on the basis
of the text itself there are indications
in the text itself that the author
didn't intend this to be taken in a sort
of wooden literalistic
way and so someone like saint augustine
for example
knew nothing of modern cosmology or
geology
um but didn't take this in a
literalistic way and i
i think that that is correct i would say
that
there are many different non-literal
ways of construing genesis 1 that are
open to biblically
faithful christians today and that are
wholly consistent and consonant with the
data of modern cosmology so as you can
see there
what we saw is william lynn craig
answering the question very frankly
he thinks that the approach that should
be applied
the hermeneutical approach is an
allegorical um or
allegorizing approach to the genesis
narrative or the creation narrative in
particular
when i looked into his website this is
what he had to say
as the reason why he does so this is
what he says he says
the author of genesis seems utterly
unconcerned
to iron out the inconsistencies between
chapter one and chapter two
that commentators have struggled with
for centuries
he does not seem to care that they're
inconsistent
an attitude suggestive of an intended
non-literal interpretation when he goes
on to
explain why he speaks about the fact
that in genesis chapter 1 that
you know the the plant had been created
on the the third day
in genesis chapter 1 verse number 14 or
verse number 12
and in genesis chapter 2 verse number 5
that no plant has sprung up yet
so he admits this is so telling and this
is extremely important
william lane craig one of the premier
apologists and scholars of the christian
world
admits candidly to one of the people
that are asking him
that there are contradictions in the
bible he admits that because of those
inconsistencies and contradictions that
there must be an allegorization
approach that is applied hermeneutically
to
the genesis creation story this is
extremely
important why because not just the fact
that it's mentioned in the quran
that if this book had been other from
other than god that would have been
left and kathira they would have found
in it many inconsistencies
but just a logical principle that if
something is true it has to fulfill
the basic criterion of consistency now
that is depending on or even if
one is depending on a coherentist
understanding of truth
and not necessarily a correspondence
theory understanding
of truth where truth must correspond
with the objective world
because one could ask a very important
question the question
someone may want to ask is why would you
have
or what use would there be of a
contradictory set
of metaphors in the bible because
they're saying it's metaphorized but why
should you have any kind of
contradiction anyway even if you have
metaphors that contradict each other
what function do they serve and does
this not
not meet unfortunately the basic
criterion for truth in so much as
it is inconsistent so this is the first
thing that you have a real hermeneutical
problem
on your hand the second thing which is
extremely
important is the fact that he stated
that the church fathers
the church fathers were allegorists
in the same way well if you really think
about it
you had an ecumenical writer or an
ecclesiastic writer origin of alexandria
who was very clear
in his allegorizing of these narratives
but the question is
why did he allegorize these narratives
and very similar for the to the reason
that craig employs he allegorized it
because
it was unintelligible if understood
literally
so before i get to that i want to take
one step back
and i will be quoting lots of
information here to prove these points
the first thing is the rabbis
in the what you call the mid rashem the
tafseer the exegesis of the bible they
all understood this
the bible to be understood in a literal
way i'm reading for example
this is the midrashim okay
and so this is what's mentioned in the
midrashim it was taught the light
which was created in the six days of
creation cannot illumine
by day because it would because it would
eclipse the light of the sun
nor by night because it was created only
to illumine by the day
then where is it is it stored up for the
righteous in the messianic future as
says moreover the light of the moon
shall be the light of the sun
and the light of the sun shall be
seven-fold the light of the days
and this is uh in isaiah chapter 30
verse number 26
and then the person who's executing this
who's a rabbi he says seven surely there
were only three since the libernaries
were created on the fourth day
so they problematized the
inconsistencies that were in the bible
but they did not allegorize the biblical
text
something different to what william lane
craig did okay this is very important
they prob
they problematized it but they did not
allegorize it
the second thing is this is their
cosmology the rabbi's cosmology in the
exegesis
they say the thickness of the firmament
equals that of the earth
compare it it is he that sitteth above
the circle of the earth isaiah 40
22 and he walketh in the circuit of the
heaven
job chapter 22 verse 14 the use of
hug in both verses teaches us they are
like so this is how the rabbis
understood it
this is one of the main
exegetes of the old testament a jewish
exegete of course
said in hanina's name
it is as thick as a metal plate all
right so these are like two metal thick
plates obviously this shows that their
cosmology was a flat earth cosmology
and that they were two like a sandwich
you know the heavens and the earth acted
like a sandwich
okay two thick plates above each other
like two fingers they say in thickness
so this clearly cannot mean
that the earth is round as some have
tried to use
uh isaiah 40 22 to indicate
now what origin as we mentioned before
mentions
is he mentions the same thing so he
problematizes
the inconsistencies in the verses but he
doesn't just stop there he allegorizes
it as a result of that problematization
so it says now what man of intelligence
will believe that the first the second
and the third day existed the evening in
the morning existed without the sun the
moon and the stars
and the first day if we may so call it
was even without heaven i do not think
anyone will doubt that these things are
made by scripture in a figurative manner
in order
that through them certain mystical
truths may be indicated
of course now the problem is you've got
two
options option one go literal and then
this is completely against science as
william lane craig himself knows
because you'd have to say that the
universe was created in six 24-hour days
and that is six thousand years old
or you go allegorical and if you go
allegorical
you've still got the problem of
contradictory metaphors the like of
which
was described by me beforehand namely
that you have the fact that the plants
were created for example in the
in the third day and in genesis chapter
two verse five no
plant has sprung up yet so you still
have these contradictory metaphors
now the thing is if we continue and we
ask another question
if you do go allegory on this and become
an allegorizer of this what would stop
you
from using this allegorization approach
in things which would be named or
understood to be
the main tenets of christianity so look
at what
origin of alexandria replied or how he
replied
when he was asked about
the crucifixion by celsus an apologist
who was a non-christian at the time he
said the events recorded to have
happened to jesus do not
possess the full view of the truth in
the mere letter and history for each
recorded event is shown to be a symbol
of something else
by those who read the scripture more
intelligently
so because celsius was interrogating him
on how could it be the case that a god
can die on a cross
if he's so powerful origin of alexandria
used an allegorization approach to at
least do away with some aspects of the
crucifixion
which may be anti-logic and this shows
you
that you can use this hermeneutical
principle to
wipe away the basic tenets of
christianity
so he mentions william lane craig
mentions
that augustine okay he allegorizes the
bible
and he mentions the church fathers and
this is actually deceptive type of
academics
because it's not the case that the
church fathers by and large
that they did this theodore and diodor
they saw that the um
that the interpretations of the bible in
genesis should be read literally
for example eusebius
john of christos jerome
and others who have we still have their
kind of
writings on their attitudes towards
origin especially in his allegorization
they didn't take the view of
allegorization so if you wanted to have
a general
and you wanted to have a rule the
general will be the literal
interpretation not just for
the rabbis who executed the bible but
also the bulk
of the church fathers who um
who exegeted the bible the rule would be
origin of alexandria who was not even
canonized in the church of the catholics
but having said that of course you have
a problem if you go with this
allegorization approach
or valid origin of alexandria then you
could be wiping away
the central tenets of christianity
why did august in the question is
because he mentions augustine why did
augustine why did he decide to
if he did because there's different
readings of it but let's assume that he
allegorized parts of the genesis
narrative though of course we must note
that he
named his book a literal interpretation
of genesis
and he had two such exegesis
why did he allegorize it so if we look
here there's something about the earth
the the heavens and other elements of
the world about the motion of the orbits
and stars
and even their size and relative
positions about the predictable eclipses
of the sun and the moon
now it's disgraceful and dangerous thing
for an infidel to hear a christian
presumably giving a meaning of the holy
scripture talking nonsense on these
topics
we should all um take all means to
prevent such an embarrassing situation
in which people
show up vast ignorance in christians and
laugh
to it it to scorn so he's doing it for
apologetic reason
reasons he was very aware of and this is
mentioned in david lindbergh's book on
these issues
he was very aware that the biblical
discourse was against the cosmologies
which were most respected and of course
he was aware of
aristotelian cosmologies and and
holistic cosmologies
and he's speaking about exegeting the
bible in a way
which is anti-cosmology of
whatever the most sophisticated
cosmologies were at that time and so the
reason why
he took the impetus if he did would be a
similar reason
that origen did in other words because
of the inconsistencies that he found of
the biblical discourse
and the external world and you can see
this again
in other places so really and truly here
i think
one can conclude it's a catch-22
situation or you can even call it
a hermeneutical dilemma if you want to
take the view of william lane craig that
the genesis narrative is allegory
then you must allow for at least the
possibility that this allegorization her
musical approach can be
applied to other more central tenants of
christianity including the crucifixion
of resurrection
this was the approach of at least origin
of alexandria who
allegorized large parts of central
doctrines in order to meet the
apologetic criterion
if one wants to say no in fact it's
literal then one will have to maintain
not only the contradictions
the internal ones but they'd have to say
that the universe is six thousand years
old
as per genesis chapter five and the
account of that and obviously the sixth
six 24-hour days
understanding in genesis chapter one
but in both cases you'd have to maintain
that there are contradictions in the
bible
and the muslim would say this why would
you believe a book with contradictions
is as simple as that
and why would you william lane craig who
is a premier christian
apologist and scholar of the christian
world candidly admit that your book is
erroneous
thereby admitting that it's not inerrant
which is one of the core doctrines of
the
evangelicals and christians more
christians
than just the evangelicals why would you
do this and continue believing in this
book as if
it is free from error why don't you seek
the truth
as your bible says and why would god be
the author of
confusion since the bible tells us that
god shall not be the author of confusion
how could god punish me for disbelieving
a book that is
fraught with contradictions in whatever
way you decide to interpret it
allegorical literal or otherwise i say
this is unfair
i say this is unjust and i say that
instead of this
one should be looking elsewhere for the
word of god
and if you want more information go to
kbih.co.uk
and download for free my article for the
proof of islam
and you will see some of the references
referred to in this video in the
description box
wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi